alright Part D explain how any correct
aspects of the students reasoning
identified in Part B are expressed by
your mathematical relationships in Part
C and explain how a relationship in Part
C correct higher relationships in Part C
correct any incorrect aspects of the
students reasoning identified in Part B
it's a bit of a mouthful but they're
just saying hey kind of connect the dots
between Part C and the two parts of Part
B refer to the relationships you wrote
in Part C not just the final answer you
obtain by manipulating those
relationships and so we can let me write
it down here so D so Part C shows us
that doubling doubling compression does
result in more potential energy
doubling compression does result in more
in more energy and you could clarify
that this is this is potential potential
and kinetic at different points in time
and then we could even draw a line to it
so we see that we see that right over
here that is that is these that line and
then that line right over there shows
that so I could draw a bit of an arrow
to it they want us to reference some of
what we saw before and just to make it
clear I can put in parentheses I can
show that u 2 is equal to 4 u 1 and that
K 2 is equal to 4 for K 1 however
however however since the kinetic energy
since the kinetic energy
is four times greater and you have the
same same force of friction force of
friction the distance is going to be
four times as a lot long the stopping
distance distance is going to be four
times as much is going to be four times
as long and even when we show the
correct parts
Part C shows us that doubling the
compression does result in more energy
and I could I could add and more
stopping distance let me do it there and
more stopping stopping distance whoops
and more stopping distance and the
stopping distance that arrow is easier
to draw and more stopping distance
however since the kinetic energy is four
times greater and you have the same
force of friction the stopping distance
is going to be four times as long and we
saw that as well over there so we're
saying hey look the student was right
that more more compression as more
energy more stopping distance however
it's going to be four times as long the
stopping distance not not two times as
not two times as far and there you go